well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what's on
the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the new statesman's deputy online
editor rachel kunliff
and the deputy editor of spiked tom
slater good evening to you both
we'll see them in a moment but first
let's take a look at what's on the front
pages and the metro is leading with the
news that more than
844 000 people received a covert vaccine
on saturday
setting a daily record for the third day
running that's also the lead in the
express eu
ban on exports could delay uk vaccine
drive by two months is the headline in
the guardian
and according to the financial times
boris johnson intends to lobby
individual european governments this
week in an effort to stifle the eu's
proposal
to block exports of the astrazeneca
vaccine to the uk
here's the mail it has seen figures
which indicate that lockdown's adding a
billion pounds a day to the national
debt
and the star has asked that the mp
johnny mercer keeps his shirt on
when he gets his jab
well let's bring in rachel cunliffe and
tom slater and start shall we with this
amazing record-breaking
day of runs we've had with the
vaccination roll out that rachel to you
first of all i mean i heard in the
united states this week that they were
inoculating around 1.2 million a day and
i thought well that's because they've
got such a
huge population but we're not far behind
that almost 900
000 in one day is something to be proud
of isn't it
it's time to be incredibly proud of but
it is so nice after a year
of doing covert related paper reviews to
start on something positive and this
really is something
very very positive um at one point uh
friday and saturday that means that
uh 26 people um sorry it's 26
per second friday and saturday which is
just absolutely incredible
and also um over half the adult
population in the uk has now had
at least one jab and we know from the
data coming in
that even though you're not fully
vaccinated with one jab it is enough
to give protection uh for a considerable
length of time and
that's something to be we should be
celebrating i remember when the vaccine
rollout plans
were first being discussed and looking
at the government's um ambitious targets
for those first nine
priority groups uh people were pointing
out that they would need to be doing 200
000 today and wondering
whether that would be possible in the
early days did we have the logistics
infrastructure to be able to do
200 000 a day well now we're doing at
over 800 000 a day with the help of gp
surgeries
um pharmacies um
vaccine super centers and it's just
an incredible achievement that we should
be very proud of tom slater um just to
bring you in now
you know we've heard so much in fact
sorry we've lost thomas
the way of the world these days is
freezing for us let's bring rachel back
in i mean we can't rest on our laurels
can we after this enormous success and
we're seeing the death rate going down
as well i think 33 recorded today
although often they are lower on sunday
a sign
of the way things are going and yet we
have this third wave on the horizon
over the channel in mainland europe
which of course has to be a worry for us
as well
well the restrictions across most of
mainland europe are these last three
months have been significantly more
relaxed than here in the uk the uk has
been under the strictest lockdown
in the developed world and while
obviously there have been restrictions
in
across europe they haven't been nearly
so severe so the
uh i i think some of those extra
lockdowns are coming now in europe
because
that wave of infection that we saw early
on in the year is now
sweeping across eu countries so that's
something to be concerned about and it
certainly
plays into minister's statements about
potential holiday plans
in in whether or not we'll be able to to
leave the country and
and have our summer holidays as normal
but it also feeds into
the the other big story which is vaccine
nationalism
and uh the the eu's uh threats
or or hints suggestions
uh depending on which way you want to
view it uh that they will halt
exports of vaccines and that can impact
britain's vaccination rates as well
which i think
um while we're having this hugely
positive story of our vaccine success
we also have to consider the context of
what the rest of europe is going to do
now in response to their own
rising infection rates i'm pleased to
say we can bring tom slater in now after
a few little teething problems there you
can have a breather rachel
uh for a second um but if you weren't
able to hear that we were just
discussing
vaccine nationalism and the worrying
threats coming from the european
commission about potentially
uh blocking vaccines coming into the uk
i mean do you think that's likely to
come
to fruition that's the lead for the
guardian tomorrow morning
are these just empty threats or is it a
real concern
i think it is it's definitely a real
concern there's even been some
stories doing the rounds on twitter this
evening that this kind of decision could
be
imminent and it would just be so
destructive not just
um for britain and our vaccine rollout
was um i think virtually just outlining
how it can set
our rollout back by two months um but
also just in terms
of vaccine production in general you
know these are very integrated
supply lines you there are various
components which are going from britain
to the eu to other countries
so raising the drawbridge in this way
could be really really disastrous but
this is just a kind of continuation
of this quite crazy strategy really that
we've seen from the eu which
on the one hand is trying to extract
more of these astronomical vaccines
from the uk's um section of them if you
like
on the other hand as we've seen in
recent weeks continuing to kind of
throw into suspicion the astrozenica
vaccine and whether or not it's actually
effective
like it's just really worrying we are
going down this road because it's going
to be
destructive not just for the countries
involved but countries around the world
who are all still
grappling with with surges and how to
get out of all of this
rachel the foreign secretary described
the threats from the european commission
as being
undemocratic and we heard the defense
secretary on sophie ridge on sunday
today
saying that the world is watching there
is pressure on the european commission
isn't there
not to exert and vaccine nationalism not
least because
we're all in this together when it comes
to covert 19 and to be depriving one
nation because they've prepared
perhaps arguably better than another
block
is not going to look good when there are
situations in worst con
positions around the world as well it
doesn't make the eu look good it didn't
make them look good
earlier on in the year when they were
suggesting that the vaccine
as tom said didn't work which is the
vaccine that they now seem desperate to
get their hands on
or when they put the good friday
agreement
at at risk by suggesting a border in
northern ireland which of course was a
a key brexit issue um they didn't look
good with that either
but i think they are panicking
especially in in the european commission
because that their vaccine rollout has
not gone smoothly partly that's to do
with
preparation as you say partly it's also
to do with vaccine hesitancy in in
countries like france
where people just have the option of
taking the vaccine but don't trust it or
don't want to take it
which the eu leaders have actually been
making much worse for themselves
and their populations and their citizens
by casting doubts
and and by that incredible decision uh
last week
to to halt the astrazeneca vaccine
over fears about blood clots which their
own medical
agency said would not justifiable
theories and they should continue on
with that roll out
it's also worth pointing out that there
is a huge stockpile of
astrazeneca vaccines in the eu i think
13 million at the start of
march which were unused because again
citizens don't want to take them so to
be
threatening to uh to halt supplies to
the uk when you can't even use the ones
that you already have
seems to be more about distracting blame
from
the the role of the commission that is
record so far than about any
meaningful attempt to protect their
citizens
uh and tom meanwhile the pressure is on
because of course the eu's meeting for
summit on thursday whether we're
discussing the possibility of a ban
uh the prime minister boris johnson uh
being described on the front of the ft
as making uh bids to uh european
capitals ahead of that summit to try and
uh build some allies in all of this i
mean is he gonna have his work cut out i
mean
i think it's the netherlands and belgium
who look likely to support us
in trying to stop that from happening
not least because of course their
involvement in the production
of the pfizer vaccine well precisely i
mean there's a line in the
in the ft story which points out i
suppose the other side which is the
issue that
the eu and the european capital would
like to
still act as one and that particularly
the commission are very irritated by
attempts to
lobby particular national capitals etc
but as you say be interesting to see how
this comes down given the fact that
there are countries who have an interest
in vetoing this but then i think
particularly because it's been clear
throughout this that france and germany
in particular
have been intimately involved in this
bizarre kind of shake down
smear campaign against britain and
astrazeneca repeating
some of those completely made-up claims
about his effectiveness that um
rachel was referring to just there it
does seem like there is still a kind of
solid core of opinion
in within european capitals if you like
which is behind this kind of
movie which is utterly shocking for all
the reasons that rachel was talking
about they are just trying to cover up
for their own failings
by digging a deeper hole for themselves
and everyone else
and you can only hope that pooler heads
will prevail with on thursday when they
meet
uh rachel it's hard to see where the
relationship will go between the uk and
the eu in this
interesting sort of post-brexit period
covert 19
and this vaccine round really uh casting
it into
on uncharted territories i think there's
a there's a lesson here for our
politicians
too which is the nationalistic rhetoric
trading petty insults which we've seen
from from both the uk government and the
eu side
over the the past five years in the
bitter brexit battle
um that does have consequences and
i i really hope and actually that the
quotes coming out from from dowling
street and from
from cabinet ministers and from the
prime minister are reassuring but they
they mark a change in in the way that
our government has
discussed uh the the the eu side
we can't just insult each other it's
actually really important that
however much uh our government might
want to show that brexit is working and
the eu might have an interest in
suggesting that perhaps it it isn't
there are
bigger issues there are there's more at
play here
and when you resort to to nationalism
and to trying to get wins and and easy
sound bites it does have real
consequences
and we do need to have a secure trading
relationship and a secured diplomatic
relationship
going forward for exactly these kinds of
reasons and that's not even getting into
the issue of our summer holidays but
we've run out of time for discussing
that rachel and tom we'll see
more from you in a moment so if you've
been watching sky news this evening
there's been lots of
violence happening in bristol between
police and protesters
but we'll be discussing that after the
break this is the inside of the metro
police left nursing broken bones after
the demo there
turns violent don't go anywhere i'll
have more on that in a moment
[Music]
for the early risers
the curious and the ones who want to be
entertained backstage sky news
welcome to is rage watch monday podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free welcome back you're watching
the press preview with me now rachel
cunliffe
and tom slater let's turn our attention
shall we to the
kill the bill protests that have turned
rather nasty in bristol this evening
they're still
ongoing but managed to make it onto the
front of some of the newspapers tom
the metro saying police have been left
nursing broken bones
this evening yes so as those protests
into the night turn violent in bristol
there's reports here
that two police officers have ended up
in the hospital at least one with a
broken arm
one with broken ribs they have uh the
protesters that is torched to police
fans and i've also been smashing windows
at one of the local
police stations um this comes in the as
you say
springing off of a peaceful protest
during the day calling
for the bill to be killed that is the
policing bill which contains
some really horrendous restrictions on
civil liberties and the right to protest
but again i don't think this um these
scenes will do that cause any favors
whatsoever not least because what the
government are trying to do is suggest
there is this new
radical dangerous form of protest which
needs to be clamped down upon
despite the fact that as we all know of
course setting light to a police plan is
already illegal as you would imagine so
this is something which i think is going
to play into that discussion but not
necessarily a good way
rachel some suggestions that there are
concerns that there could be
more protests in the coming days in a
similar vein to
the london riots that we saw in 2011
uh priti patel under pressure i suppose
um well i actually think this is doing
principles hell a favor she wants to get
an incredibly draconian piece of
legislation passed
which would see people potentially at
risk of being jailed for being a part of
demonstrations which are too noisy
the point of a protest is to be a bit
noisy but obviously not to be anything
like horrific scenes
like we're seeing in in bristol tonight
and i think this place straight into her
hands the government is saying
that they need tougher powers even
though as tom said setting fire to a
police van and violence against the
police
is already illegal you don't need a new
law
in order to clamp down on those kinds of
protests but i think it's going
to be used by as fodder by the
government they just handed the
government ammunition
well let's end on a slightly lighter
note shall we uh finish in a story on
the front of the star tom i don't know
if you've had your vaccination yet or if
you've thought about what you will wear
or what you won't wear
when you do is it a shirt on shirt off
kind of event
well if i was following the example of
johnny mercer there also lord bethel the
health minister who put out a slightly
strange video of him
was getting his vaccination over the
weekend um this seems to be
what tory mp's doing for when they're
posing for their vaccine shot so the
daily star
with a campaign there that we can all
get behind keep your kids on when tory
mps pose for their
vaccines and why do you think they're
doing it rachel i mean is this a sort of
macho thing we know johnny mercer to be
a sort of macho mp don't we
i don't know maybe they don't want the
public to see their taste in t-shirts
possibly
um it's not it's not an item of clothing
you normally see mps
where i actually disagree i think it's
great because if they're if they're
shirtless they want to be shirtless
they're more likely to have a photo op
so photos are more likely to be in the
papers
and people are more likely to see
government ministers and mps getting
those vaccinations which is going to
encourage other people
to come forward so if they want to take
their tops off it's fine with me gosh i
suppose that applies across the board
then to male and female mps or whoever
it may be who knows if it gets published
he gets people taking a vaccine
then why not